Okay. So our task today
is to finish up teaching,
uh,
about roles.
And then I'm going to take
a step back and look at the,
where we've gotten to
so far in today's cores,
because we're really entering
a transition moment, uh,
from the enlightenment to
the Anti Enlightenment,
which with which is what
we'll begin with on Wednesday.
So we had just, just to recap briefly, um,
we had been talking about roles
as two principles of justice,
which were really three
principles of justice.
One for the distribution of liberties,
which was his most expansive system,
consistent,
a compatible with the like liberty for
one specific principle of equality,
of opportunity,
which is to be in his lexical ranking,
which was some reason known only to John
Rawls comes before two a and the third
one was to a,
this,
this so called difference principle
or what used to be called in welfare
economics, the Maxine men
principle, which says,
maximize the minimum.
Cher and I had explained to you why
Rawls thinks the standpoint of justice is
the standpoint of the
most adversely affected,
which is not a bleeding heart idea,
but rather this universal izable idea,
this notion that if you
can affirm a principal,
even from the standpoint of that those
people who are most adversely affected by
it, you'll affirm it from every
other conceivable standpoint as well.
And so this translated into these
L-shaped indifference curves her,
if we start with a distribution like that,
um,
anywhere in this area would be preferred
because all roles is interested in is
it is maximizing that distance.
Um,
that is the, the, the size
of the share at the bottom.
He seem different to who has that share.
Um,
so that say an x to move from x to f of
here would be an improvement for roles
even though, um, it's,
it's a clearly a massive loss
to a and a huge gain to be a,
he's not interested in that. The point
is that the distance from the, the,
um,
access to f is greater here than the
distance from the axis to x is there.
And that's the only key.
That's the only relevant consideration.
Um,
now,
sometimes roles is called an egalitarian
and as I began to point out to you at
the end of Wednesday's lecture,
that's really misleading.
His principal is rather
very undead determined.
That is to say,
um,
if we compare it with
the parade principle,
it's completely contains within
it the parade oh principle.
So that if somebody came along and said,
well,
the best way to benefit the people
at the bottom is to have markets,
um,
trickled down,
let's say that that the pie will grow the
most and the people at the bottom will
benefit the most from
a pure market system.
Roles would say fine.
Um,
because everything that is Paredo
superior is also rolls preferred.
On the other hand,
if somebody came and made the case that
heavy state intervention to redistribute
would in fact work to the greatest
benefit of the least advantaged,
then he would agree with that as well.
And so you can conjure up,
um,
egalitarian results that a compatible,
uh,
with the roles he and scheme or
Anti-gang attarian results of further
consideration comes in here.
When we stopped just talking about
the worst off individual because,
um, you can start to think about, well,
what happens if you get a small marginal
increment for the person at the bottom,
um,
paid for by massive cuts on the middle
class and perhaps big benefits to the
very wealthy.
And I mentioned the example of
the Reagan tax cuts in the 1980s,
which had that structure roles would
have no objection to that either,
even though from an
egalitarian perspective that
would look like I regress of
redistribution, uh, from
the status quo in 1980.
Um,
so it's a very under determined principle.
It's not necessarily egalitarian or
necessarily anti-gang attarian all it says
is arrange things to the greatest
benefit of the person at the bottom.
And I,
as I think I mentioned to you,
roles took a lot of criticism in the
1970s in 1980s from people who would plow
all the way through to page 300
and whatever it is in his book, uh,
to learn that role says he's agnostic
between capitalism and socialism.
And people say,
well,
to read 300 pages of a book about justice
and discover the author is agnostic
between the two main political ICAN
economic systems of the 20th century is an
exactly, um, satisfying. Um,
but roles as answer as I said is which
type of political economic system
actually operates to.
The benefit of the person at the
bottom is not a question for political
theorists.
That's a question maybe for a political
maybe for trial and error through policy
innovation.
Um,
it's going to have to get hammered out
in the real world of practical political
economy.
And so it's not a critique of
their roles in standard that,
um,
it's undetermined with respect to the
choice of actual political economic
systems.
And I think that Rawls is on
relatively firm ground there.
We wouldn't want to think that what,
what political economy is
the most efficient from the
standpoint of benefiting
people at the bottom is really
a philosophical question
when clearly it is not.
So that's the roles in story.
I gave you the big picture
at the beginning, uh, his,
his general conception
of distributive justice.
And then these more specific principles
that get added in the course of trying
to figure out, um, how the,
the general conception of justice can,
can actually be applied.
Now I want to take a step back.
I'm going to come back to
roles a little bit later,
but I want to take a step back first and,
and think about where we've come from.
Uh, and then we'll see how roles, uh,
leads us to think about
where we've gotten to.
We started out this course by
talking about enlightenment,
political theory,
the enlightenment being a philosophical
movement that really starts in the 17th
century but gathers steam
in the 18th century.
And I said that fall from the point
of view of political arrangements,
there were really two core
values of the enlightenment.
One was to a commitment to the idea of
individual freedom as realized through a
doctrine of individual rights as the
most important value in politics.
And the second was a commitment to
science reason and science as the basis of
politics rather than things that had
prevailed hit a to such as natural law or
tradition or natural rights or religious
argument that rare that the move,
which we source so dramatically
with Bentham but has been present,
he won our way or another with everybody
we've looked at. The move is to say,
no, we're not going to appeal
to tradition. We're not
going to appeal to religion.
We're not going to appeal to
natural law and natural rights.
We're going to appeal
to the idea of science.
Science understood through reason.
And so those are the two twin ideas,
which one way or another have shaped every
single theorist that we've looked at.
So starting with the
commitment to science,
remember those early enlightenment
theorists were very different from modern
enlightenment thinkers in that they
identified science with certainty.
Remember the,
the I,
the Cartesian idea that you have certainty
about the contents of your own mind
or locks, uh, locks point that,
that only we have that kind of privileged
access into the contents of our own
soul. Remember his famous
line to the effect that,
um,
true and Inwood a true and
lasting conviction requires
inward persuasion of the
mind. And that can't be
forced on anybody, uh,
by the magistrate or,
or anybody else.
That this is internal
certainty is so important.
And for Hobbs, we saw that, um,
it's this w knowledge has
its basis in willing thing.
So, um, we got this raw,
the curious result that he
said, you know, uh, the,
the laws of geometry have the force
of laws because they're the product of
wills. We make the triangle, if you like.
And the laws of politics were like the
laws of geometry because we make the
Commonwealth in the same way that we
make the triangle a and that therefore,
in the early enlightenment,
there was this,
this enormous emphasis on certainty
as the hallmark of science.
But then we saw as we moved into the
mature enlightenment with people like John
Stuart Mill, that actually they had
a very different view of science,
that the hallmark of science was fallible.
Isn't that everything we think,
we know a is subject to doubt.
There isn't anything in, in, uh,
reasoning about the real world that
meets the Cartesian a criterion of being
impossible to doubt what we think we
know is always revisable in the light of
more evidence, uh, and,
and bed scientific investigation and
mills defense of the marketplace,
of ideas and of competition.
Uh,
and argument was precisely
to encourage that. And so,
um, the longs chapter on freedom
of thought and action in,
uh,
in on liberty is really about,
remember how we get from, from, uh,
freedom to utility via a system
that allows the truth to come out,
name me a system in which ideas have
to confront contrarian ideas in the
marketplace, uh, of public
speech. And that, that, that, uh,
science is, is it really
a process, uh, which,
which makes it possible or more possible
than any other process for us to
approximate the truth.
But that's something very different
from having this notion of certainty.
So the commitment to science becomes
the commitment to Falabella awesome.
Uh, and the commitment
to assist them, which,
which has room in it
for, um, experimental,
uh,
searching after the truth as an as
a perpetual feature of human social
association.
Now when we look at Rawls and Nozick
and the social contract theorists,
um,
we find in at least in some respects,
it's sort of throw back to the
early enlightenment at least in the,
in the Nozick and the roles that you've,
we've talked about today.
That is to say,
um,
they are looking for a unique
answer to the question,
what principles would people agree upon
if they would designing society of fresh
and the,
this hypothetical social contract a so
called depends on the idea that there's a
unique answer to that question,
right?
So they can see that there never
was a social contract, but they say,
suppose we were designing
the rules from scratch,
what rules would we design even though
no society was having created in that
way? And the the, the thought was, well,
if there's an answer to that question,
if there's a definitive answer to that
question, then we have a standard,
a yardstick for measuring actual
institutional arrangements.
That is to say societies that come closer
to that standard can be judged better
than societies that are further from it.
And as societies evolve over time,
if they evolve toward it,
there'll be improving and if
they evolved away from it,
they would be getting worse.
So this was the Cancerian or I called neo
con t and aspiration to come up with a
standard which any rational
person must on reflection, affirm.
And if you can say what that is,
then you have your yardstick by
reference to which you can look at actual
political and social arrangements and
it might be worth pausing just for a
second to notice that
Emmanuel concave himself,
who we did and read it in this course.
So you'll have to just
take it on faith from me.
Conn himself was deeply skeptical that
that could be done because he thought
that social and political arrangements
are inevitably dependent on empirical
considerations.
And you're not going to get you an
the universal laws about those things.
So conn himself would have been skeptical
of the roles in a project you to say,
you're not going to be able
to get empirical propositions
about the organization
of society that are going to rise to
this level of a categorical imperative.
And I think that that one implication
about discussion of roles is that con was
in fact right,
that um,
for example, um, roles,
a story about protecting the position
of the person at the bottom as tsums an
enormous degree of risk aversion.
Now he had an answer for why he said,
well,
there's no necessary relationship between
the level of economic development and
what the,
the fortunes of the person at the bottom.
So you had that graves risk assumption,
but we saw that even that
becomes problematic if you
think about very marginal
improvements in the condition that the
person at the bottom coming at enormous
costs for the person a
little bit higher up.
It's not at all clear that the rational
thing to do would be always to add,
no matter what cost to preserve the
condition of the person at the bottom.
Important a article about this
published by John Harsanyi in 1975,
I'll use that. If you
really think that, um,
people have a rational view of risk,
it would make more sense to choose
utilitarian Nissam behind the veil of
ignorance. Then it would
make to choose, uh,
the Rawlsian commitment to,
uh,
maximizing the position of
the person at the bottom.
Now it's not obvious
that Harsanyi is right,
but nor is it obvious that rolls is right.
And once you,
once you make that, um, admission,
then you no longer have a
unique answer. You say, well,
we plugged one set of
psychological assumptions in
about risk and we get roles,
we play a different set of assumptions
of in about risk and we get Harsanyi.
And so it's all being driven by the
assumptions about human psychology that we
plug into the model.
And of course, once you,
you recognize that,
then you don't have a unique answer.
Um,
another way of putting it is that the
young roles was rather naive about what is
uncontroversial in economics,
psychology and sociology that is rolls
made a distinction between the laws of
psychology and economics as he put them,
uh,
which we do have knowledge of behind
the veil of ignorance in which he was
treating as uncontroversial.
And then the specific knowledge that we
have about our particular life plans,
goals and so on,
which he kept hidden from us.
But it turns out that there are very few
uncontroversial assumptions about human
psychology or economics and so
you can't get unique answers.
And indeed, uh, if we own a
restrict ourselves to economics,
one of the most interesting developments
in economics of the past decade is
precisely the turn away from standard
economistic assumptions into the field of
psychology to see how
preferences are formed,
why people have the risk
profiles that they do and so on.
And much of modern behavioral economics
regards as subjects with study rather
than the thing,
then a axiomatic assumptions,
the sorts of things roles
wanted to work with.
So there isn't a unique answer.
Now,
as it turns out,
as roles became a older,
he realized that this neo con tn venture
was belt upon a hell of sand and that
he wasn't going to be able to make cons,
ethics,
do the work and social contract theory
that traditionally had been done by
natural law that for the
reason that I just gave you,
you're not going to actually be able
to get unique results out of it.
And so the mature rolls made
a different kind of move,
which in some ways is an even bigger
retreat from the early enlightenment then
was males retreat to Falabella.
Awesome.
And that is the move that comes
under the heading of political,
not metaphysical.
And that's the name of the sub title
of the article I had you reading about,
uh,
for today.
And so he is the intuition.
It's counterintuitive and Ted
Hughes thinking it through. Um,
but then I think it's actually
quite a powerful intuition. Um,
and I'm going to,
I'm going to explain it to you actually,
not by reference to roles,
but by another person called Cass Sunstein
who's a lawyer at the University of
Chicago who might want,
you might hear a lot about him cause
he's on the long short list, uh,
for Obama picks for the Supreme Court.
Uh,
so cass Sunstein might be
in the news stay tuned,
but Sunstein has had a different slogan,
not political,
not metaphysical,
but rather what he called a theory of
in incompletely theorized agreement.
Now let these, this is not an elegant
term, but let me give you the, the,
um,
the intuition here.
We often think when we think about
political disagreement, we often think,
well,
people are Kinda agree on very general
things and the devil is in the details.
People can agree, you
know, that read is good,
but they can't agree on what is
actually required for freedom.
When you get down to brass
tacks of arguing about policies,
you know,
mmm.
Does having universal is this freedom
require people have universal health care?
Some people say yes, some
people say no. All right. So,
so one view of political disagreement
is we can agree at a very high altitude,
but then when you start to get into,
uh,
the dirty particulars of everyday
life, uh, then we can't agree.
Okay.
Sunstein and roles in his political
not metaphysical mode have the almost
opposite tuition to that.
And so, so here the, the,
the sort of example would be,
well,
okay,
think about a,
a faculty in the university trying to
decide whether or not a junior person
should get tenure.
They might be able to agree
that the person should get
tenure without being able
to agree in a million years about
why the person should get tenure.
Or when we think of Congress
passing a piece of legislation,
when we think of Congress
passing the healthcare bill, uh,
that just went through a warts
and all through the house.
MMM.
You know,
you get the votes,
but if those people have to agree
upon why they were voting for,
they couldn't, they couldn't
agree in the mail. Yeah.
If they all have different reasons for
why they're voting for it or why they're
voting against it for that matter.
Right.
So the notion of incompletely
theorized agreement is, you know,
why we don't care,
we don't care or rolls this idea
of political, not metaphysical,
it's,
it's the question is what political
arrangements would people with very
different values, commitments,
worldviews, metaphysical systems,
what would they agree on?
What would be to use
another one of Rose's terms?
What would be the overlapping consensus?
Thank you. Sort of, you know,
a big Venn diagram was where
you've gotten a lot of circles.
Mostly not overlapping,
but they all overlap at
[inaudible] in one area.
Okay.
That's the overlapping.
And we don't care about the
parts that don't overlap.
So we,
it's,
it's much less rationalistic.
Lee ambitious.
Cause now if you think back
to the first principle,
we don't have to say that
the fundamentalist would
agree that she or he has as
much free,
has more freedom in a disestablished
church regime than the non fundamentalist
would have in the fundamentalist regime.
All we have to say is that the,
the fundamentalist accepts this.
We don't know why.
We don't care why.
So that's the notion of incompletely
theorized agreement or political,
not metaphysical. We're just
going to look for water where it,
what is the overlapping consensus for
people with very different worldviews,
metaphysical systems,
beliefs, et cetera. Okay?
And so, so another way you
can think about this is,
okay,
instead of saying,
first I'm going to convince you of my
metaphysics and epistemology and my theory
of science, and then when I've
persuaded you about all of those things,
I'm going to show you how
my political theory follows
on this. Sunstein or mature
role's view. That's a Mug's game.
You never going to do it because people
are never going to agree about all of
those things.
And more important for politics.
We know need them to agree
about all of those things.
All we need to do is find
the overlapping consensus,
uh,
uh, that they will affirm. So they might,
they might affirm a series of,
of political arrangements,
institutions for very different reasons
from one another. And it doesn't matter.
We don't need it to be
any more robust than that.
And so that's where the
mature roles winds up.
And as we'll see in the final
lectures of this course,
there is a certain
democratic element to this,
but it's under theorized in roles.
And I, and the, the analogy I will,
I'll just mention and I'll come back to
it later in the course is the analogy is
the secret ballot.
Okay.
We don't require people to give
reasons for the way in which they vote.
They can have reasons for choosing the
same candidate as we choose that we would
regard as completely idiotic.
We don't care.
Okay.
Right. So there's this,
the, this political,
not metaphysical move or the
incompletely theorized agreement move is,
is analogous to the idea of the secret
ballot in that we become much less of,
people don't have to have good
reasons for voting the way they do
their reasons are there private business.
Okay.
And so the political,
not metaphysical move bills
on that kind of intuition.
And obviously it's a huge retreat from
the original enlightenment motivation to
get principles that must
follow scientifically.
MMM.
For any clear headed thinking person.
So the mature roles is a,
is a kind of extreme
retreat you might say,
even though the young
roles is, is uh, you know,
an enlightenment thinker with
all the zeal of a Jeremy Bentham,
the mature roles really gives up
on the enlightenment project. Um,
and of course you then
get into the question,
he still thinks his is three
principles would be affirmed.
He thinks these three principles
are part of the, of, of,
or are part of this overlapping consensus.
But he has no way of knowing that that in
fact is true. Uh, it just an assertion,
uh, that it's true and we,
it's not necessarily the case.
So,
um,
what I'm going to suggest to you in later
lectures that is that rolls actually
retreats too far from the enlightenment
project and that there's a way of
thinking about the mature enlightenment
that's consistent with, um,
uh,
democratic political outlook that
doesn't give up so completely as the
political,
not metaphysical view dies
on the alignment project.
But that's for the future.
Let's first focus on the other
element of the enlightenment.
I said the, the, the one was
this commitment to science.
And we've seen how that played out now
from the 17th century to the late 20th
century in this gradual
re this affirmation.
But this gradual retreat from certainty
that mark the march from the
early enlightenment thinkers
through mail two roles
Sunstein and others.
But now let's focus on the idea,
the normative idea of individual rights.
Remember we said that,
um,
the most input,
the sooner bonem the most
important value of the,
of the enlightenment.
This,
this idea of individual
freedom recognized or,
or institutionalized by
doctrine of individual rights,
the rights of the individual
are somehow sacrosanct.
And we saw that in the
early enlightenment.
This had a theological basis.
Remember I said to you that,
uh,
lock was tormented by the theological
controversy between the two sides.
Uh, some of them said, uh, uh,
God is omnipotent. But if you said
God is omnipotent, that seemed to,
uh,
undermine the idea that the laws of
nature could be timeless because if God is
omnipotent, he could chai it, decided
to change them tomorrow. So, uh,
either God is omnipotent or the laws
of nature of time has been not both.
And he wrestled with that.
If you've gone and read his essays on
the law of nature, published in 1660,
you see him really tormenting himself.
But at the end of his life,
he comes down firmly on the,
on what we call the will based theory,
the idea that something can be a law
unless it's a product of a well. And so,
um,
we'll go with the omnipotence and let
the omniscience fall by and let the
universalism fall by the wayside.
And so that was the idea,
uh, of, uh,
God owns his creation because he made
it and God knows his creation because he
made it.
And then the move lock makes is that God
gave us the capacity to make things for
ourselves. We become,
as he called, you know,
miniature gods that so long as we act
within the constraints of the law of
nature, we can behave, uh,
in our realm in a way that's an analogy
of the way God behaves in his realm.
We can create,
uh,
things over which we have make
us knowledge just as God created,
make us knowledge,
uh,
and rights of proprietorship
over his creation.
This idea that we are miniature God.
And then we saw what happened
to that idea, that work.
We called it the workmanship model. We saw
what had happened, what happened to it.
Um, over the course of the next
several centuries in particular,
we saw that beginning with marks.
What you get is an attempt to secularize
the workmanship idea that is to say,
to cut it loose from its theological
moorings but still affirm the basic
structure of the idea that
making confers ownership.
And um,
we saw that Mark's,
his version of that ran into trouble
because he wanted to say only the worker
makes things when in fact
we saw the capitalist also
contributes to the value of
things. And then we looked at the feminist
critique of marks, which was, well,
yes.
And the stay at home spouse contributes
to the value of what the work can makes.
And indeed,
even perhaps the Sunday school teacher
who drum the work ethic into the worker
can contributes to the value of
what the word come makes and so on.
So that if you have this idea
that making confers ownership,
you're going to get a complicated
web of overlapping and indecipherable
entitlements,
not any clean argument of the sort that
Marx's theory of exploitation aspired to
be. And so, um, we,
we saw that if you look
at the Marxist tradition,
they eventually give up on all of that.
People like John Roemer and
Yon Elster and Jerry Cohen.
And instead just turn,
they give up on the idea of workmanship
and turn to an argument arguments about
power.
Um,
but most people wouldn't find that
entirely satisfying because most people do
want at some level to link
what we get to what we do.
People, I'm not, even if the,
the notion of workmanship is problematic.
Most people don't want
to give it up entirely.
And I think you see this very
dramatically with roles because roles
takes the idea of workmanship apart in
a hardheaded way that nobody before him
ever did. He, and this is, this is the,
the debate Irie I was referring to last
Wednesday about nature and nurture and
moral arbitrariness.
Just to remind you,
there's this huge debate it's gone on
for 150 years are the differences between
us.
The result of nature will,
are they the result of nurture and
roles makes the point, you know what,
it doesn't matter. It doesn't make
any difference because in either case,
these differences are morally
arbitrary. Right? Remember this? Yeah.
So,
um,
whether I'm a good athlete because of
my genes or whether I'm a good athlete
because of the way I was
raised is immaterial.
I did nothing to have certain genes
or to be raised in a certain way.
Uh, and I didn't even make choices
that lead to those results.
So any benefits I'd get a morally
arbitrary. That was the notion,
uh, that that roles, uh, brought to bear.
But then the question is,
well,
why should anyone be
entitled to what they make?
And,
and you know,
roles is really pushed in the
direction of a kind of socialization of
capacities, strategy as I call
it. It, that piece that I had,
you read it.
But it's very unsatisfying
because, you know, if,
if I spend five years writing a book,
uh,
and you come along and say, well, you're
not entitled to that book. You didn't,
you didn't, you don't have any
special claim on the capacities.
You I want to get really bad. You know,
I worked really hard on that. I wanted,
it's mine. You know, who do you
take it away, right? So the,
so even if you can't give a good
philosophical defense of this workmanship
ideal, people are deeply
unwilling to let go of it.
Okay. Indeed. So it's raw,
steeply, unwilling to let go of it.
So roles and we walked through this on
Wednesday, but I'll just remind you,
I'm it again.
Rawls makes a distinction between,
um,
the capacities that we have and they use,
we choose to make or those capacities,
but that's not very,
uh, you know, the, the,
the notion was so, um,
if we both have the same Iq but one of
us chooses to work and the artist chooses
to sit on the couch watching ESPN,
the one who works should get
more because they chose to work.
And then the person who sits on the couch
should get less because they chose not
to work.
Um,
but that doesn't really work for roles
because once you've made the move into
this a land of moral arbitrary ness,
the difference differences in weakness
of the will are themselves distributed in
morally arbitrary ways.
So perhaps, uh, you know,
the,
the person who works all day had the
work ethic drummed into them a mile a
minute by some hot Sunday school
teacher or very involved parent.
Whereas the one who winds up
sitting on the couch all day,
didn't their parent, their
father was, you know,
off stoned all day or something when
they were supposed to be being, uh,
taught the work ethic.
Well if the capacities
themselves are morally arbitrary,
then the differences in the capacity to
use the capacities is so you're going to
get obviously an infinite regress.
So roles tries to kind of build a moat
around this implication of his argument,
but it doesn't work.
And if you,
if we had time to talk about
other theorists in this tradition,
you'd find the same thing.
I'll just mention the example of Ronald
Dworkin whom who also liked roles has a
resources to view and also like rolls
sees that the differences between us,
a morally arbitrary, which they are. Um,
and he says,
well,
we should make a distinction between
what he calls material resources people
have,
which is sort of like Rawlsian primary
goods and physical and mental powers.
And we should treat the differences in
material resources as morally arbitrary
but not the differences in physical
and mental coward. But again,
you have to come back and say,
why not he,
while we couldn't redistribute them, but
actually that's not true. For instance,
think about blind people. You could
have a system which said, well,
if some people are blind,
we have to compensate them for their
blindness because they have a and morally
arbitrary disadvantage, right? Or indeed,
if you really want it
to be brutal about it,
but it's nothing in the logic of what do,
what can sang rules are that we should
just blind all the sighted people, right?
Well, maybe the technology, we get
forcible, I transplant it's not a path.
People are gonna want to go
down, right? It's not a path.
People are gonna want to go down,
but it's hard to see
why not.
Right? It's hard to see why not once you
take this idea of moral arbitrariness.
Seriously.
So two points to make about that.
We got back to the very beginning.
This was never a problem for lock,
right? And we should remember that
because after all of this comes from Loc,
uh, this workmanship model comes
from Loc. Why is it not a problem?
A lock?
Because for lock,
if we have differences in capacities,
it must've been God's
plan, right? Remember,
lock story is human
beings are God's creation.
Human beings do not
create other human beings.
He's very clear about this in his
discussion of parental rights.
We don't own our children in the way
that we own our property because we don't
create children. God creates
children and he, he, you know,
he implants in,
in human beings the urge to reproduce.
But we can't, we don't
fashion the child. We can,
we can create a child in, in an
architectural sense. And most importantly,
of course for lock, we don't put the salt
and the child. So God does all of that.
So children are God's property
and parents are fight usury.
So we don't own our children.
So if it turns out that some
of us are smarter than others,
or some of us are more hard working
than others and some of us are better
athletes than others,
we don't have to,
there's no moral
imperative for us to have some account
of why those differences exist.
Um, because they're not, they're
not products of human action,
that products of the divine joy.
So,
so in the Lockian story,
this isn't a problem,
but the minute you secularize
the workmanship ideal,
this issue arises a quiescent
that some people should get more than
others just because of morally arbitrary
characteristics and the,
um,
the,
the ways in which people who have gone
down this path try to not get to the end
of it, aren't very Roosevelt. Right.
I mentioned roles.
I mentioned Dworkin.
We could have looked at some others I talk
about in that piece. Jerry Cohen Beer,
one of them.
But it doesn't work.
So you're left with the fact that if you
embrace the socialization of capacity
strategy,
you're going to get to a place
that very few of us want to go to.
Now it's actually even worse than that.
It's even more problematic
than that because
everything I've said
to you so far presumes
that in the absence of a
justification for inequality,
we should presume equality off parole.
I said,
why should somebody get more
just because they work hard?
If the capacity to work, is it
south, morally arbitrary, right?
That presumes that,
uh,
there's some assumption that
other things being equal,
we should all get the same.
But why assume that?
Why assume that
we could just say,
wow,
it's not a divine plan. So, you know,
some people are lucky and some
people are lucky. There it is. Um,
losses miss lie where they fall
as a famous American judge,
one set and gains should lie where
they fall and so you could get nature.
We'll hear a little bit more about nature
when we read Alistair Mcintyre. Uh,
next week you could get
the view that you know,
this strong when you know,
and it just the way it is, uh,
any asking moral questions
about it is simply irrelevant.
Now,
Rawls thinks he has an answer to that,
which is what I started with at the
very beginning of the roles lectures,
which was essentially,
remember when we had the discussion
of watch the fairway to cut a cake.
And one of you said,
wow,
the fair way to cut a cake is to give the
knife to the person who takes the last
slice and um,
then he will divided equally
or she will divide it equally.
Big preside machine being the person
wants to maximize the slice that they get,
the residual slice. So that, and the
way you do that is to divide it equally.
Bye.
I made
the point that that's not
really an argument for
equality, right? That's not a,
a moral argument for equality.
It's not a moral argument for equality
because it assumes what we want to get is
equality and then you create the,
the,
the mechanism to generate that result.
So if for example,
we added more information and
we said well we know that this,
the six people here waiting
for the slice of cake,
one of them has three cakes at home
and one of them has nothing and one of
them is a diabetic and one as you know,
you could, as soon as you
introduce information of that sort,
then it's not obvious where you
want to wind up is equality.
And so giving them get st
to the person with a knife,
you get the last slice
becomes problematic, right?
So all of this is only to make the point
that the cake cutting example does not
establish the moral desirability
of equality. On the contrary,
it assumes you've decided equality's
where you want to end up and then you
create a mechanism that generates it.
And that's the structure of what
roles does in his theory of justice.
He assumes that his principles of where
we want to end up and then he structures
the choice situation to generate them.
But it means if you favorite quality or
if you favor efficiency or if you favor
some other basis for distribution,
you have to have an argument for it.
Some other argument for it other than
just that it gets generated in this way.
And to the extent roles has any argument
at all. It's this kind of prudence,
this there, but for fortune
go I the grave risks, um,
we better take care of the person at the
bottom cause it might turn out to be me.
Um,
but as we saw that assumes a view of
risk that some people find irrationally
conservative.
Um,
and so we don't really have
a clear clean cut answer.
And so we don't really have
a very satisfying evolution
of the workmanship ideal
from locked down through the present.
It's a theological argument in locks
formulation. It's got this very nice,
coherent all fits together.
But the moment you try to secularize it,
you left with this problem that it leads
into directions people are not going to
want to go in on the one hand.
On the other hand,
they're not going to want to
get rid of it entirely either.
And so the ways in which people try
and hedge in the parade of horribles,
um,
doesn't entirely work.
And we're left with this kind of nagging
feeling that there's gotta be some way
to salvage this workmanship idea,
but we haven't managed to do it.
And so just as the evolution of science
has taken us with the evolution of the
commitment to science,
it's taken us to a rather uncomfortable
end point when we get to the world of
political,
not metaphysical.
So the evolution of the workmanship ideal
has taken us to a rather uncomfortable
and point once we get to roles as move
and his attempt to limit the radical
implications of it that he doesn't like.
And so we will pick up that story when
we come to talk about the democratic
tradition in the last few
lectures of this course.
But before we get there,
we're going to couldn't fit as
seriously the idea that may be the whole
enlightenment project was a mistake.
Maybe we should reject the
whole enlightenment venture.
This was of course,
the view of Edmund Burke Irish political
thinker that we'll talk about on
Wednesday. And it's, it's a,
it's a long tradition from
Burke down through the present.
We're going to look at Alisdair
Macintyre as a contemporary, uh,
a defender of this view.
But this is the idea that we shouldn't
be surprised that the enlightenment
project turns out to be untenable
because it was a profound and indeed
politically dangerous mistake.
We'll start with that on Wednesday.